disparos y explosiones en la madrugada
de este viernes un grupo de militares se
tomó las calles de la capital de burkina
faso y cortó el acceso a edificios
administrativos antes de llegar al
mediodía ya se habían cerrado las
escuelas negocios y bancos y la
televisión Estatal dejó de transmitir
con escenas muy similares a las del 24
de enero cuando una junta militar
encabezada por el coronel Paul Henry
damiba tomó El poder del país y desplazó
al presidente roca caboré los ciudadanos
sintieron el ambiente de un golpe de
estado y salieron a las calles a apoyar
a los uniformados hemos orado a Dios
para que sea un golpe de estado nosotros
pensamos que la llegada del presidente
de amiba iba a ayudar pero estamos
viendo que está más interesado en
hacernos daño frente al mundo Francia lo
envió queremos que él y Francia abandone
en nuestro país queremos cooperación con
Rusia a las 8 de la noche hora local la
presencia de un grupo de soldados en
televisión nacional confirmó lo que los
ciudadanos esperaban el nuevo lí al
Capitán Y brahim traoré lamentablemente
nuestro ideal común fue traicionado por
nuestro líder en quien habíamos
depositado toda nuestra confianza lejos
de liberar los territorios ocupados las
áreas que alguna vez fueron pacíficas
han quedado bajo el control de grupos
armados terroristas nuestro valiente
pueblo ha sufrido bastante y sigue
sufriendo
la junta militar anunció el cierre de
las fronteras de burkina faso
indefinidamente Se suspendió la
Constitución así como todas las
actividades políticas los golpes han
sido impulsados en parte por la
violencia cometida por grupos islamistas
que se han apoderado de grandes áreas
del norte de burkina fazio y partes de
los vecinos Mali y níger namiba había
derrocado al ex presidente roca caboré
en enero en parte por la misma razón la
cdao condenó la nueva toma de poder el
país había sido suspendido del bloque
regional tras el golpe de enero pero se
había pactado una transición de dos años
para el retorno de elecciones
democráticas